can writers hold on to their characters
too tightly yeah for sure yeah in fact
uh yeah I'm always saying we got we got
to hold it loosely if if you're our idea
of our characters is never the whole
character in fact it drives me crazy
when writers say oh my character would
never do that
I think of drama as characters behaving
uncharacteristically okay so a nun robs
a bank you know a bank robber saves a
child on the way out of the bank it's
when you're writing a story or imagining
the world of a story and a character
does something that seems out of
character our job is to trust that and
be curious about how to support it
rather than going my character would
never do that characters can do anything
if you can find a way to support it so
when someone says that and you challenge
them do you find that most writers back
down or do they become so stubborn in
their ideas of who that character is
that they're they're not willing to bend
well I don't cheat I don't I don't teach
like that so I don't like I mean if I if
I if I have a care if I have a student
who's challenging me then what what is
there to challenge I'm not I'm just
asking questions it's the way I teach
it's the Socratic method I'm not I'm not
rakonin ever my my yeah so I I would
never have that with with one of my
students I would just say you know why
do you make that choice that's a
question I always asked my students why
do you make that choice you know why why
does the character do that and and it's
either in other words you've got we've
got to be willing to explore blind
alleys so if if we just assume that our
story's going in a particular direction
then we might be denying ourselves you
know a lot of riches by not exploring
the the opposite way I always say to my
writers if you know your characters
gonna go left you have to go right in
other words if if in
scene bill is gonna propose to Sally and
Sally's gonna say yes that's not an
interesting scene Sally will you marry
me yes I will bill that's not a scene
there's no meaning that gets conveyed
convey get the meaning gets conveyed
through conflict or tension and so we
want to explore all the reasons why bill
can't get married and all the reasons
why Sally is afraid to say yes then now
now we're gonna understand what the
scenes about because the scene isn't
about Bill proposing to Sally the scene
is about Bill being afraid to work for
Sally's father you know what I mean
will you work what you know Sally will
you work will you marry me and then we
can spend our lives and I can write tone
poems and she's like no I actually if
I'm gonna marry you you're gonna need to
come work for my dad the hit man you
know now we've got a story okay so we
get you if you know you're gonna go left
go right if you think your characters
gonna do this hold that loosely because
you're going to discover that that that
your idea of your character isn't though
isn't the whole characters on that it's
incorrect it's incomplete and and and
the irony is that when you hold it
loosely your character actually becomes
the most full version of the character
you imagined it's not going to do
exactly what you wanted it he or she to
do but it's actually going to become you
know the goal of storytelling is for the
whole to be greater than the sum of its
parts not to be the sum of its parts
you